But I want to switch gear a
little bit in the talking about
another place where
intelligence would come up.
That is really intelligent
digital assistant.
Cortana, I want to
talk about Cortana.
I'm sure by now you have heard
a lot of intelligent assistance.
Popping up from many,
many companies you definitely
have a question that,
so what's so unique about
the Microsoft Cortana.
I tell you two things about
the Microsoft Cortana
that's really unique.
Number one,
Cortana is really designed for
you to go across your work life,
your work and life.
And as you can imagine that,
the lines between work and life.
Are really blurry.
Just think about that, your
email accounts that you use at
home and that you use at work.
So this is why we
actually design Cortana
to be the best digital assistant
to help you to get things done.
Whether at home,
at work or on the go.
And for example, Cortana will
help you to find the emails and
to remind you your commitments.
You may or
may not already forgotten.
And the recommended
meeting times.
Or shared accounts.
So this is why that we
actually have now the support,
to really help you to work
across different email systems.
So we actually now can work
in an added GMail support for
calendar and the email, so
that Cortana can help you get
across multiple email systems.
So I'm very happy to announce
that we actually have this
ability today, in Cortana you
will see a demo very soon.
So the second thing very
unique about the Cortana,
I want to share with you is
that it's not really about
our own Cortana devices only.
So we really want to bring
Cortana to as many devices as
possible.
And we, for example,
launched this Harman Kardon
speaker recently.
With a beautiful voice quality
and all those digital assistance
qualities, and
the user experience.
And we also announced
a partnership with Cortana and
Alexa, and with Amazon.
Because we actually believe that
it's important that we offer
very unique user experience.
Especially across work and
life on different devices.
But that's not all,
we also wanted Cortana to appear
in as many applications
as possible.
In whether it's Microsoft own
Windows, and Office, and others,
and all Android and iOS
applications in other platforms.
So this why I'm so excited
to announce two new mobile
launchers on Android platform.
Our own Microsoft launcher and
Cheetah Mobile.
And our partner they
actually have one of those
top productivity launchers in
Android Google Play store.
And the Cheetah Mobile Launcher
will be available immediate
with our Cortana embedded and
the Microsoft Launcher will have
Cortana capability in
the couple of months.
So, this integration with
Cortana is now we do that to
help more people across
multiple platforms.
It's really coming back to my
earlier point that is, you think
about that the lines between
work and life getting blurred.
Why did you need an assistant?
Where did you need an assistant?
So, this is really
in our commitment,
to help people to get
things done even faster.
So, one thing I want to remind
everyone is that as we design
those digital assistants,
like Cortana it's really
about the conversational AI.
It's really not just about
you have one question, and
then you get an answer, and
then you get out of there.
It's really encouraging you
to get into the dialogue.
So I wanted to invite Kristina
to come up to show you some of
those interesting Cortana demos,
Kristina?
>> Thanks, Harry.
So first and foremost,
Cortana is a fantastic workplace
productivity assistant.
It can help with things that
normally take a lot of time and
a lot of steps.
One example is finding time
with my very busy VP, Jordi.
Hey, Cortana,
set up a meeting called FY
18 goals with Jordi Ribas.
>> Looks like you and
Jordi are both free at 9:30
am on monday January 8th.
When would you like to meet?
>> 9:30 am on January 8th.
>> Okay I've scheduled this
FY 18 goals with you and
Judy at 9:30 AM on Monday
January 8th, is that right?
>> Yes.
>> Got it.
>> January,
I told you he was busy.
Before today I would have wasted
a lot of time going back and
forth trying to figure out
when we are both free.
But now with Cortana, because
it understands my calendar and
Jordi's calendar, it can suggest
the time that's best for
both of us.
Beyond a pure workplace
productivity assistant,
we all know, as Harry said,
that the line between work and
home is blurring more and
more each day.
The real value in Cortana is
in its ability to move across
devices and across the different
aspects of our lives.
It's difficult to
schedule a work
trip if you don't know what's
on your personal calendar.
And we all know that sometimes
the most urgent email that you
receive during a work day
is from a family member, or
from a friend.
Cortana summarizes across your
different email accounts.
Hey, Cortana.
What new emails do I have.
>> You've got six new
email in the last hour,
one from Haddon Park
marked important,
three from Helm Williams and
two from Jodi Ribas.
Which center do you
wanna hear more about?
>> Adam please
>> Adam core email view about
holidays.
Marked important.
Wanna hear it?
>> Yes, please.
>> It says Don't forget
to buy cirque tickets for
your parents visit.
What do you think
about a Friday?
Answer me,
what should I do with this?
Reply or nothing?
>> Nothing.
>> All right.
>> We are all
really busy people.
But because Cortana
blends my work and
personal life by reaching across
my different email accounts.
I can take care of
things as they come up.
Of course I could set a reminder
and take care of this later.
But there is no time
like the present.
The problem is,
I don't actually remember when
my parents are coming to town.
Hey, Cortana.
Find mom and dad on my calendar.
>> You have mom and dad visiting
at Seattle from Wednesday,
December 20th to Wednesday,
December 27th.
>> Okay.
Because Cortana is about
helping you wherever you are.
It's support integration across
calendars with Office 365,
Outlook, and now even Gmail.
Hey, Cortana.
Help me find tickets to Cirque
Dreams Holidaze in Seattle on
December, 22n d.
>> I have 3 skills
that can help you.
Ticketmaster, Gigseeker,
and Stub Hub.
Which do you want to use.
>> Ticketmaster please.
>> Okay.
Opening Ticketmaster.
I found Cirque Dreams Holidaze
in Seattle on December 22nd at
7:30 PM.
Tickets are $40 to $80.
Do you want to pick your seat or
buy the best seats available?
>> Best seats available please.
>> Okay,
how many seats do you need?
>> Four, please.
>> Okay,
I found four seats row D.
Seats six to nine.
Sound good?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, I have four seats for
Cirque Dreams Holidaze
at the Paramount Theater
in Seattle on Friday,
December 22nd at 7:30 PM.
The total comes out to $394.
Say confirm to purchase.
>> Confirm.
>> Okay, you're all set.
Would you like me to add
this to your calendar?
>> Yes.
Please also invite Adam.
Okay, I've sent this
event to Adam Kirk and
added it to your calendar.
>> Thank you for letting
me get that taken care of.
Now let me walk you through some
of the cool things that just
happened here.
Instead of me needing to know
which specific skill to ask for,
Cortana used skill suggestion to
connect me to the best
place to buy tickets.
And then connected me to
the that third party skill.
And because of my, I have my
credit card information with
ticket Master, my purchase
process was a breeze.
Cortana then use a new feature
called skill chaining,
which understand my
overall intent to help me
find the next most
relevant skill.
In this case, it was adding
an events to my calendar.
How great was that?
Using my voice, Cortana was able
to help me be super productive
in both work and at home.
All of this done hands-free.
This calendar feature
is available now.
The next generation of
our Cortana skills kit is
also available today.
And the email features that
we demoed today will be
available next month.
But of course Cortana can help
you in more places than just
this great speaker.
Here's a quick look in some of
the places that Cortana can help
you be more productive.
And get things done across
Windows, Edge, Skype and
the new mobile launchers.
[MUSIC]
>> Hey,
Cortana,
play my
dance
mix.
[MUSIC]
>> I booked your workout for
6:00 pm tonight.
Can I get you a ride?
[MUSIC]
Hey Cortana.
What's next?
>> It's really amazing to
see how Cortana has evolved
into a really powerful
digital assistant.